so what would you say your anime taste
star what kind of like anime do you
actually like
like what kind of anime do you gravitate
towards I think like I watched a lot of
Shonen obviously like which is part of
the reason why I think the characters
are supposed to be teenage because like
they're for teenagers yep mainly yeah um
but I mean that and and I guess like
I I know what I don't like and it's just
like romance stuff or like cute [__]
like I'm not into any of that yeah at
all that's fair are you into like
heavily political stuff not as in like
exploring like different political ideas
no not even like I I don't I get excited
when I see something that I that I
recognize as like political within the
anime yeah but it's not something I like
seek out at all right like I've never
watched uh what's it called Code Geass
um
no I've never watched it and everyone
says like that's well is it it's Mecca
and I don't like Mecha anime but like
from what I understand all the mecca
animes are like literally the most like
yeah
I think the original I think it's maybe
Gundam
um that that's like straight up written
by communist like no no like an actual
like I think Communist Party communist
if I'm not mistaken really I don't wanna
yeah I don't want to say the wrong thing
maybe that's
it's like it's like snake something
maybe what is it
oh God the original gum seed
maybe the original gun the original
Gundam yeah yeah maybe I don't know I'll
look it up
yeah yeah like one of the one of the
first ever like uh Gundams ever created
was like straight up I think made by
like a like a communist card carrying
you know Japanese Communist Party member
all out yeah so like Gundam Gundams do
have a history of like being very
political yeah I mean yeah most meccas
are except for like the Super Robot kind
of like genre most meccas are heavily
steeped in you know different political
ideas most likely inspired from shows
like Gundam right yeah yeah exactly I
mean Gundam started the real Mecca kind
of genre and a lot of them kind of like
similar to attack on Titan you know
where there's a lot of politics and
Attack on Titans right yes you'd love
code kiosks yeah I mean I'll we'll see I
just we'll see you know the art style is
like really important to me too and I
when I see like um the old school like
very big face uh our style like it just
I can't guess get like really into
school
so many things except for old school and
I would have accepted that it's not it's
not that it's old school but like it
does kind of have that like like unique
look right yeah yeah yeah I would say
because wait but hold on you sat through
Bucky
you can't get more unique than that it's
like the ugliest anime yeah yeah but
it's beautiful
I love I just I love like it's the same
like Jojo it's like just muscular
behemoths you know it's so sick because
we need more of that anime yeah I love
it no me too if you love that then you
should watch first of the North Star if
this is oh I've heard about that one
yeah that that is definitely awesome
yeah yeah that is kind of like I think
what you know did this Northstar come
before Jojo I think it did yeah it did
yeah
oh okay yeah
that's a really classic anime do you
watch old anime at all because I feel
like a lot of people now if it gets past
a certain point where it becomes like
hand drawn anime a lot of people aren't
interested I love hand-drawn though I do
I do like hand-drawn anime too but yeah
it's uh it depends it totally depends
like sometimes it's harder to get into I
mean I look I I watched all of the old
one-piece episodes you know what I mean
that's politics
yeah like and and it was definitely like
significantly slower in the beginning
too oh yeah so we're going for more like
Saturday morning cartoons yeah like
telling a serious story yeah so I think
a lot of filler as well
yeah the website's dedicated to letting
you skip oh I I use that like I use the
pace I have the I don't use one page
because I I don't want to download it
because like it's too much work
um but I use like the filler anime uh
website this animes to tell you which
one uh yeah yeah it's so it's so clutch
because like I mean I can't even tell
sometimes when it's like very clearly
filler oh yeah yeah yeah like especially
when they don't feature like any of the
main characters oh yeah yeah and it was
just like why did you make this episode
Hunter Hunter
is too long
that's a that's a commentary okay okay
that was like you're just so mad at me
when I say this well I mean a lot of
people like the camera around I don't
know I like it it's great yeah but like
if you if you literally just look at the
episodes or chapters comparatively it is
like more than everything else combined
before it yeah
um because it's like what 80 episodes in
the anime yeah it's it's like it's like
it's like half the anime I feel like and
in the anime is 144 or something and
it's it's most of it yeah and it's long
it is long and I think the first part of
the camaron arc was a little bit slow a
little bit slow and then and then Hunter
Hunter greatest pedophile villain of all
time
people will go online to defend a
pedophile if he's kind of cool yeah yeah
yeah they shouldn't have made him so
cool
because he's like he's like the
strongest guy yeah they should have been
like that's a bad guy and he's weak yeah
he's like literally the most like the
strongest mysterious character in the
show I feel like they would like just
they really limit tested that because
they're you know his psych has always
been like a creepy character right and
then there's the scene where he
literally says I'm getting an erection
right yeah and it's just like okay okay
I don't know if that's limit testing at
that point they broke through
[Applause]
one of the most epic fights in the manga
yeah is uh between uh this was his name
crawler
yeah and uh hisoka yeah they fight in
the manga and it's like insane it's like
the most insane fight if you can get
through his really bad manga drawings oh
yeah oh well they well he usually
repatches it for the actual volumes yeah
he would if it's been canceled now so oh
really yeah so it's not happening
anymore but um uh he did not because of
the pedophile
[Music]
does in the series
that doesn't get you canceled in Japan
yeah
um we gotta finish it dude over
completion is his drawings were like so
bad uh it's because he had a seriously
at that point you're like just just wait
just just hold up why don't they like
you can't have someone else like try to
recreate it don't Monica's also have
like you know
apprenticeshi is like known as like a
super perfectionist like yeah I think
during you haksho he didn't have a
single assistant like he drew all that
himself but like I mean overworked to
death oh yeah he's been going through
some bad health and that's been like
pretty well known so I mean
yeah yeah I mean we were unfortunate
yeah I mean I think after what happened
to uh contaro Miura like berserk's
author yeah yeah I think the every every
Monica is like oh this is a thing that
can happen now okay I better look after
myself and I think luckily I think after
that fans are a lot more understanding
about I finally have an excuse to
actually start hunt Hunter now now that
I know it's not coming back
finally so finally I can start reading
it yeah I feel like just like some of
the most iconic facts in anime are in
Hunter Hunter there's just so many bang
of fights that uh don't drag on too long
also political you got Health Care wait
wait wait wait wait wait wait wait wait
wait the [__] what's the guy I
deserve so long since I watched it but
the main guy oh
why is he even involved
why is he involved because he wants to
[__] pay for health care
it's true
not American take well you just see
Healthcare like that's about me no I'm
just saying like but that's literally
why he wants to do because he's like he
needs to pay for health care and then uh
Healthcare another odor reference back
to [__] uh the snow Island whichever
whatever yeah yeah yeah that's it yeah
drum island is literally about
paywalling Healthcare
[__]
arrest every doctor and he's like I'm
gonna control the health care now you
may not like it but this is what the US
will be like in two years
how do you watch that and not realize
that
I thought like oh the doctors it ain't
that deep Bro
I felt like it wasn't that deep no it
100 is that no no it is not that I will
ride dude I hope I hope Odo watches your
podcast dude
Okay the reason I don't think is it's
that deep is because most the world
don't really think about healthcare
because it's nice yeah
he sees how bad it is he's like drum
island is very similar to America
you got the magical witch at the top
yeah
[Music]